au cours d'une émission précédente et
dans le cadre des micro trottoirs de
gérard pas bio nous vous parlions des
chèques aux mains oui il semblerait qu'à
l'époque de l'informatique et des
micro-ordinateurs l'algèbre la géométrie
la trigonométrie reste la quadrature du
cercle dans nous en tout cas nous savons
déjà que le carré de l'hypoténuse n'est
pas un fromage auvergnats et que les
sous-ensembles n'ont rien à voir avec la
lingerie intime que la différence entre
l'abc zeller données n'a rien à voir
avec la façon de ranger son petit
intérieur et que les produits de facteur
ne sont pas forcément distribués par les
employés des postes
riche de ses enseignements suivons donc
à nouveau notre facétieux barbu parti
chasser les parenthèses et soumettre ces
problèmes-là plusieurs inconnues si je
vous dis une masse conique
qu'est ce que c'est votre avis si le
gros celui qui comprennent une une fille
qui était grossier comp
et pourquoi je suis les insultes à quoi
sert la table de logarithmes à votre
avis alors
avoir plusieurs expressions dans tata
sont aptes à ton mail à la java là là là
ça sera un jour de pour remplacer un ou
deux musiciens qu'est ce que c'est que
la table de logarithmes c'est une table
qui remplace
trois ou quatre musiciens des fois mais
qu'est ce qu'on trouve sur cette table
plusieurs définitions de chansons comme
gagner un exemple la halle à la honte à
toi tu as ton dos lâche ou ne sais pas -
c'est des gens comme ça quoi vous allez
le savoir quand même oui moi je sais pas
ce que j'en ai vu mais on en avait vu ou
des tables de logarithmes surtout dans
les orchestres qui servent de tout ça
ouais enfin pour moi que j'ai vu il n'a
peut-être pas aussi l'étape de
logarithmes oui peut-être
les mathématiques ou des trucs comme ça
non pour pas de table de logarithmes les
maths sur ses surnoms l'effraction qu'en
pensez-vous dans un problème je pense
qu'il faut qu'il y ait fraction dans
tout problème
pourquoi sinon les assurances ne paye
pas la science ne paye pas si on si on
ouvre une porte sans laisser de trace
les assurances ne veulent pas payer
comment peut-on calculer la valeur de pi
à votre avis madame c'est parce que ça
ne se calcule pas cette façon je pense
qu'il faut calculer le nombre de litres
à la journée c'est qu'une vache est
capable de donner 40 litres de lait si
elle a 4 pi qui fonctionne bien ou est
ce que bon bah sinon la valeur de piste
se calcule pas quand je vous dis 3 14
116 à votre avis aubin le banc des reds
reviennent non la région parisienne
pourquoi le baril je te donne des voix
baril mais comment imaginez-vous la psy
c'est leur donner madame c'est pas la
personne ordonnait évidemment sa maison
tout de suite bien rangé
et puis c'est peut-être aussi une
personne qui a les pieds sur terre
disent à leurs données et leurs 6 et
l'abc ce bon bah elle s'en va et les
mieux courir dehors et évidemment elle
est peut-être plus utile à la société
c'est certain mais il faut les deux même
si fait une différence entre la psy
c'est leur donnèrent oui exactement
exactement enfin on a peut-être plus
confiance dans leur donner
[Applaudissements]
avec tous ces micro trottoir nous valent
un ample courrier la france est assez
partagée et là dessus mais enfin il ya
bien 10 ou 15 mai pour une contre alors
on décide de continuer les gens qui nous
disent mais vous donnez un curieux
visage de notre pays l'ignorance et
cetera mais au fond vous êtes tous
compris qu'il s'agissait surtout d'un
sourire
[Musique]